tell us more about India's commitment
and how it compares to other countries
here hi good morning well you know it's
significant that India as you mentioned
is the the world's you know it's the
last holdout of the major economies to
put its commitments down so you know
what that means is that it's part of the
process it's part of the discussion so
that's quite good but you know it's it's
really important to remember that the
stakes are quite high for the global
talks of course but the stakes are also
quite high for india india is home to
the world's most polluted city New Delhi
has the world's dirtiest air it's also
home to a 13 of the world's 20 most
polluted cities and it has got to
balance the the the idea of cutting
emissions with the idea of economic
growth so there's a lot at stake here ok
so do you think this is going to
kick-start India's investment in
renewables and and where is this money
gonna come from anyway uh well what this
does is it really validates what the
Prime Minister Prime Minister Modi has
been saying about renewables in India's
commitment India's goals for renewables
are really quite aggressive they're
hoping to install something like 175
gigawatts of capacity over the next
little while and the commitments that
were put down yesterday we're saying
that it'll get about forty percent of
its primary energy from non-fossil fuels
by 2030 how does it do that where does
the money come from well the commitment
yesterday was saying India expects that
a lot of them the money and a lot of the
help will come from outside India so you
know from from green funds outside from
commitments from places like the Asian
Development Bank and from the World Bank
and also from other countries so again
it's a validation but it's also calling
for outside support okay so there's that
and what does India's commitment not to
cut but to slow things down mean in
terms of actually reaching a global
agreement in Paris
again that's a really quite a
significant part of this statement so
India is is not saying that it's going
to peak its emissions it's not saying
that you know China has come out and
said well by 2030 that it expects its
emissions to peak other major economies
like the u.s. they're saying that
they're actually going to have absolute
cuts what India is saying and what this
commitment really reflects again are the
competing challenges of controlling
emissions but also acknowledging that
there's going to be quite a bit of
economic growth in India which of course
will be energy intensive and in in a
sense again it reflects what the Indian
policy makers have been saying all along
which is look we are a growing economy
we expect to keep growing we expect that
our emissions will keep growing really
that's what it's all about we expect our
missions to keep growing but that there
we acknowledge also that it needs to be
done in a controlled manner